okay when we go ahead and get started so
welcome to our Thursday research
conference we're going to here to
practice presentations today of two
groups that are presenting early next
week at the AMIA annual symposium into
student design challenge which is is
actually a competition that ohsu owns
our one of our teams have finished first
the last couple years and I think
there's been a couple others that have
done well and there is some three of
them in the finalists to our will be
presenting so they're going to do their
practice practice sessions today and I
also just want to mention to everyone um
you've seen my friends here my eight
friends from Thailand in fact they're
going to be joining the fellows meeting
after this talk and I've invited them to
listen in as well so I will let you all
present and introduce yourselves I'll do
the timing because I know that your
presentations are time so we'll let
people do the the two presenters do
their presentations and then we can
spend some time giving them feedback or
asking any questions
okay my name is Vincent Caruso this is
Matt stumbling we are two of a group of
four that worked on this design for the
AMIA student design challenge and today
we're going to talk to you about chronic
disease monitoring with the precision
patient ledger this here is a mia
student design challenge focused on
engaging providers and patients and
precision medicine and with our design
we've tried to address all five of these
bullet points but we have especially
focused on the two highlighted ones
which is patient and provider engagement
with their data as well as ways to
better inform decision making so as we
started thinking about how to respond to
the design challenge we quickly focused
on chronic disease management and we
realize that because patient patients
with chronic conditions only theater
providers intermittently but the
condition persists it doesn't go away in
between there's potentially a lot of
missing information that could be used
to improve decision-making about their
condition and management so this gave us
an idea a general idea of a precision
patient ledger which would be a tool
that would enlist the patient to
self-report their data in a way that
would it would become part of their
medical record and available to their
clinician and their care team for making
better decisions about their care but we
also realized that we wanted to focus on
valuable data so we focused on collect
only collecting data that was curated by
the clinician or the care team so it
would have a potentially high impact for
their for their condition and they're in
their management and then specific
specifically we learned through our
research that something as simple as
physical function has been shown in a
number of cases to be the most important
predictor of all-cause mortality for a
wide range of chronic conditions so this
is kind of what set us up on our path
serendipitously as we were talking about
these big ideas we in discussions with a
Rheumatologist colleague of ours we came
up with she presented us with a use case
that actually gave us the perfect
example to apply these ideas into our
specific design which is what we'll go
into now so to introduce the use case
I'm going to start with a very simple
case study so meet Rachel Rachel lives
in burns Oregon she where she cares for
her three children and she has a 15-year
history of rheumatoid arthritis
currently her disease is well controlled
with standard medication and Rachel
typically visits for rheumatologists at
ohsu about every three months for labs
and follow-up however as you can see
from this map of Oregon burns which is
in the rural eastern part of the state
is quite a ways away from any of the
rheumatology clinics in Oregon which are
represented by these red circles so for
Rachel to visit her rheumatologist at
ohsu it's at least a five hour drive one
way just for one visit so this presents
two part problems first of all there's a
major travel burden for patients like
Rachel with chronic disease who live in
rural areas and secondly because she
only sees her clinician a few times a
year there's relatively sparse data
available to her care team for making
decisions about her management so this
this means that there's a lot of missing
between visit information and patients
and their care team are currently making
important decisions about the disease
management based on a very incomplete
story and I also want to point out that
travel burden in this case for rachel is
one of distance getting to the clinic
but burden can mean different things for
different patients so it's not just a
unique problem for rural patients
so for our design we focused on
collecting data in the form of the rapid
three the rapid three is a clinically
validated tool that measures physical
function which I had mentioned earlier
the rapid three is very simple as you
can see from this example question it
can be filled out in about five minutes
so present a minimal time burden for the
patient but it is also a clinically
validated tool so its maximum benefit
for that for that short investment rapid
free also has the advantage of being
familiar if you talk to a Rheumatologist
chances are that they're already using
it in their clinical practice when their
patients come in and because rapid free
is clinically validated in fact it's
been shown to have higher prognostic
value than lab results and other
clinical measures the rapid three is
actionable for making care decisions so
there's few components to our design
implementation the first as you see here
these are screenshots of a simple mobile
app this would be what the patient uses
to enter their rapid three scores or
there to answer questions about the
rapid three the idea is a patient would
complete one of these self assessments
on some periodic basis that they would
agree upon in the discussion with their
provider for example Rachel's
rheumatologist might prescribe that she
fill out the rapid three every other
week in between their appointments
now currently this gets to how do we get
the data to the provider this graphic
gives you an example of what clinicians
might see currently in the in the health
record and let me just say right up
front this is not awesome the tabular
format is very rich there's a lot of
data represented here but I think we can
agree that it's a little bit hard to
read and interpret especially regarding
longitudinal trends this is inherently
longitudinal data but it's very
difficult to interpret that from the
tabular format so the second component
of our design is simply a graphical
representation this is the data
visualization for the provider that
would be integrated into the electronic
health record for example this could be
part of an epic navigator that the
physician might use during or just prior
to a visit or it could be part of the
navigator that the care manager uses to
periodically review a patient case maybe
in between visits to sort of to see how
they're doing this is I think much
easier obviously much easier to
interpret the longitudinal trends this
graphic can also be annotated in various
ways for example this dotted line as
rapid three scores go up that's an
indication that physical function is
worsening so low scores are good high
scores are bad the dotted line could be
some patient defined or threshold that
alerts the provider or the care manager
that there may be an issue there may be
a problem that needs to be responded to
also critical events from the patient's
medical record can be annotated such as
surgeries or medication changes which
are shown by the blue and red circles
here so the goals for this design are
threefold first of all we want to
stimulate discussion the idea is that if
the care team or the provider can review
this data just prior to a visit they'll
be on the same
age with the patient they'll both both
have a general understanding of how the
patient's been since the last time they
saw each other and they can make the
most of their time together second of
all by having this more complete picture
higher density of rapid three data we
believe that that we can improve
decision-making between the patient and
the provider and finally for example in
Rachel's case for people who have a
significant burden about in terms of
getting to the clinic we might be able
to reduce unnecessary care visits so
this can improve patient satisfaction
with their care management hopefully
improve their quality of life for
example at the end of this graph you see
that this patient's Rachel's condition
has been stable for the last several
weeks maybe she doesn't need to come in
for her next visit and maybe they can
agree that she stays home for now and
checks in sort of the watchful waiting
model and now I'll turn it over to Matt
to discuss some implementation
so I'm going to talk a little bit about
the underlying technology components of
our design you can see here the we
converted the clinically validated tool
to sort of paper questionnaire into a
patient facing mobile app mobile app
because we wanted to really maximize
accessibility we want to be able to use
standardized and come and commonly use
home devices mobile devices tablets
computers whatever and to allow the
patient flexibility for entering this
information from wherever they are
another concern was about robust
communication this really has two
components to it one we were concerned
about of course like encryption and
protection of patient medical
information adhering to HIPAA standards
and so forth and protecting that
information as well as intermittent
connectivity if some of these patients
are relying on mobile technology and
there's intermittent access to the cell
cell network that we want to make sure
we were robust and how he handled that
data it was cached and then later
appropriately communicated to the
central server and lastly we wanted to
really integrate with the EHR this is
about reducing impact on overall
workflow and making the data highly
available to the physicians the tool
that they're already using of a care
manager and so throughout this this
entire blog platform we wanted as
flexible as possible so we use the fire
standard to really standardize our data
communication and storage our team was
aware that we didn't know what our final
design would look like when we started
we had some ideas and so we knew that we
wanted to have fast iterations to really
be responsive to as we learn more about
the needs that we could adapt our design
and so we adhere to an agile design
process and where we knew that tight
communication within our group and with
our stakeholders was important we also
know that we want to do fast around and
fast iterations to really refine our
design as soon as we had any sort of
feedback and so we we also use a user
centric design we work in constant
communication with our stakeholders
specifically a physician and talk about
their their expected needs from this app
and so we moved pretty quickly from a
whiteboard to storyboard to a mock ups
into actual fully functioning prototype
in a relatively short period of time and
so
that ultimately led to this written Stan
Shih ation of the prototypes is our
current version and you know we we were
really a conscientious about
accessibility to the user about using
standard common user interface motifs
and so forth and our current feedback
right now is that the font is too small
so our next iteration will address that
to make sure that those were for ice I
could use it there was five design
principles that our group really kept
core went out throughout this entire
process first of all we want to focus on
a specific and realistic problem we want
to make sure that this was going to be
ultimately logistically feasible to
instantiate and be adapted by clinicians
we wanted to focus on a high impact data
we wanted whatever data we did collect
was going to be actionable that could be
clinically useful for decision-making
and we want to leverage current
technology and create a flexible
platform because not all chronic
diseases are exactly the same we
designed this for rheumatology rumor a
rheumatoid arthritis but we want to make
sure that we could adjust to other
chronic diseases or other clinically
clinically validated tools and other
types of data types that they may want
to acquire and ultimately we want to
make an incremental step forward and
this is about making minimal impact on
workflow we want to really like to
really speak to the idea that we want to
make this highly adoptable we want
clinicians to really have buy-in and
want to use this once we had a working
prototype we went to the rheumatologist
here on campus and we gathered feedback
and we asked them among other questions
of the most important question I think
is would you use this app or something
similar to it in your clinical practices
yes maybe no it was interesting the most
useful feedback we got was from those
who said maybe and no that helps us
identify some really important known
concerns and so we distilled those known
concerns here and so these are some
quotes sort of like summarizing their
their feedback for us a smartphone app
is too challenging for some of my
patients and this really is speaking to
patient education patient education is
key not all patients are equally
computer literate or ready for this
there's been studies that shown that it
was a oncology study UNC Chapel Hill
they found the most computer and
experience patients actually
show the greatest improvement in
outcomes with some patient education on
how to use this type of tool so we think
that patient education is key for making
something like this really work another
concern and this is from the physicians
perspective i'm unable to constantly
monitor my patients between visits we
know that clinicians are busy we know
that and so we had sort of envisioned
that this could be integrated into the
workflow more of a place where it's on
demand by the clinician or the care
coordinator and the data would be
reviewed at or just prior to a visit so
then they can have an overall view of
how the patient's been doing right
before they arrived or before they
interact and the second thing that we
identified is that you have to set
expectations for the patients yes
they're using this app on an ongoing
basis they've been told every two weeks
but they should know that the position
may not be looking at this quite at the
same frequency and it will only be at
the point of visit setting expectations
is key and lastly is another concern
that highlight is I'm concerned my
patients will get discouraged if they
are constantly reminded of their poor
rabbit three score and this speaks to a
phenomenon like survey fatigue or
unknown psychological effects of this
type of like sort of medical medical app
and so we would need to sort of get at
that question by doing an IRB approved
study the Seas and you know to assess
this effect on the patient some future
developments going away I went by
okay thank you this is my second last
item some basic future development so
we've already identified would be
valuable would be patient centered
visualizations this is so they can
interact with their own data as of now
they just into one way and we know that
it'd be more useful to have sort of
close the loop with the patient we also
thought about expanding to other
validated clinical tools appropriate for
other other chronic diseases and maybe
enabling provider generated parameters
if a physician thinks that some
information is appropriate for managing
care for their patients we can allow
them to gather that data as well this is
the last point I'll make Ted Pincus who
is a Rheumatologist in New York and the
creator of rapid free form and I has
been doing a lot of this work for a
number of years he said that poor
physical function maybe in a sense the
most reversible risk factor for
mortality and this really speaks to the
high impact value of gathering this type
of data tracking physical function with
regard to chronic disease and so we
think it really reinforces that this
design could have high impact for both
patients and then overall coordinated
care so to say thank you to my own team
for all our work and all the support we
got we got a lot of a lot of help from a
lot of people at ohsu and just say shout
out thanks to all of them I know we're
showing time so i would probably say
that it's early and funding for national
library of medicine do i have to
actually say that by the way thank you
any questions
okay so yeah the circles of different
sizes it it's not very clear from this
graphic I guess but the large circles
are intended to represent data points
from a visit an appointment and the
smaller ones are all the data points
between appointments so there's a
sponsor from the legend
you
it's it's not theoretical because we
actually investigated all those key
technology components and link them all
together using fire and actually in
interacting with in with an
instantiation of epic it wasn't the ohsu
live epic because you know we don't have
access to that but we actually did play
with all the key technology components
to link them all together so it's not
fully developed into a useful
application for the physician side
however all the key points are all the
key components are already instantiated
so we could then develop up from there
so the boilerplate technology is there
and operationalize yeah yeah yeah yeah
you
you
ok
kind of two questions one is this actual
patients data or you know or like have
you collected you know over a year's
worth of intermediate data points where
people are being monitored with rapid
three on their own or is this kind of
like simulated this is what it could
look like this is this assimilate this
is this we didn't use any patients
information so i guess the piggies that
question is kind of once you have that
kind of data where it's actually been
been used is there any thought to
evaluating the claim that filling in the
data point this way would actually
improve the physicians a ability to make
a judgment when did you come in
yeah yes I thought this was interesting
case because it's a survey kind of
measurement so I think I think that's
somewhat of an unanswered question and
that's also why that would be the point
of pursuit of taking this further with
an IRB study and it's also something
that you know this is necessarily
simulated data because we can't
ethically track a patient without having
IRB approval and we haven't has the
scope for the time to do that yet
as far as rheumatology and rapid three I
think it's largely in the hypothesis
stage right now
so this is much better than you know
about the patient come as a person of
the additional comments little bit so
this is perfect so out of curiosity have
you had the opportunity yet to go back
and try to deep breathe and converse
with the positions that provided these
comments exactly what they meant because
it seems like this 15 meaning as a
couple times before just good at
multiple meanings yeah I think actually
the problem here is the wording that
we've used to can convince it because
their comments were clear what we meant
to convey here is a technological gap
especially for older patients okay they
were specific about those yeah they also
made the comment which I think it's also
confused with that it may be difficult
for patients with rheumatoid arthritis
specifically to operate the app that's
another way that it could be difficult
although we also were told that their
patients are already doing this with
pencil and paper which is arguably
arguably much more difficult than doing
it with a smartphone app where you can
tap with a knuckle or a stylus or
anything so if they're able to do it
with pencil and paper this should just
be a lower bar but mostly the
technological challenge is there and
perhaps something we haven't stressed
enough is that it really to get this
design off the ground or there needs to
be a patient education component that is
not depending on the position we see
this as being perhaps a nurse educator
or medical assistant working in the
clinic in a hospital this could be a
larger department that's sort of like
analogous to tech support except for
their they're right there it's like the
physician would prescribe certain data
collection measures and then you go to
the support team and they help set up
your technology so that it at the right
frequency with the right collection
measures and make sure the patients know
how to use it
thank you okay we have our next group
and let me remind people in the audience
when you ask a question there's actually
people listening to the web stream and
they couldn't hear all the questions so
let me just remind everyone to press on
the microphone not so much that we can
hear it in here but that people who are
viewing can hear it so this is team
number two there are three entries so
we're guaranteed the department to win
at least second or third place okay
should we acknowledge the third team
raise your hands 13
hi and I'm steep I want to thank you all
for coming and letting us practice at
you today so we're the team obviously
were one of the other teams from ohsu we
chose social determinants of health
azhar for our entry to our type of
precision medicine to focus on for the
Amy design challenge entry and we
created for this entry we created an
application called social view which is
designed to overlay an EHR and to make
social determinants visible and also
actionable during the in the midst of a
clinic visit so this is a really general
description so for people not familiar
with social determinants of health
assist from the CDC website conditions
in the places where people live learn
work and play affect the wide range of
health risks and outcomes these
conditions are known as socially terms
of health so that's really general
question is what what impact these
factors have on health so this is a kind
of a quick graphic just to show the
impact of different different influences
on health outcomes of get social
determinants healthcare system biology
which includes genetics and environment
so the top are the social determinants
of health of fifty percent and the main
thing we wanted to sort of show here is
that the that social determinants is
actually a greater influence than the
health care system and biology combined
so so while in the spirit of precision
medicine while genetics can guide guide
us to a specific treatment for
specification the social determinants
helpless help determine where that
patient actually has access to the
treatments so this is usually thought of
as public health data and there's been
historically a disconnect between you
know social determined to clinical data
in in a clinic visit these two are not
really available at the same time so in
2014 the institute of medicine published
this report where they recommended
bringing social determinants into an
electronic health record or capturing
them in an electronic health record to
make them available during a visit and
they came up with 12 characteristics and
this is this is where we started this is
sort of the foundation of where we
started with our application development
so our design goals so obviously we want
to bring all this data together we want
to bring the social
into an EHR into a clinic visits but we
want it to be really visible and not get
lost in it you know kind of buried in an
EHR which is been a problem we wanted
integrate it with the clinic that you
know the social data with the clinical
data so there so it kind of flows or the
clinic visits and in an efficient way
doesn't interfere or add more burden to
a clinic visit and not only doing on to
stata to be there and easy to work with
we want also want this application to
guide clinicians and patients to
resources or you know solutions to the
issues that might come up with social
determinants so that the nice thing is
that a lot of times if these resources
are already available in communities
it's just that nothing brings the social
and clinical and the resources all
together in a clinic visit you know in a
nice way that flows with the visit so
our target setting or medical homes uses
the interdisciplinary care team in the
medical and we chose to focus on
diabetes for this project it can really
be applied to a lot of medical
conditions with diabetes is influenced a
lot by can be in phone swap by social
determines as well so we're going to
jump into the we're going to jump into
the demonstration of the application now
and to do this we're going to do in a
case study format and i'm just going to
walk through it like like i'm using it
in a clinic visit and we've created a
fictitious patient natalia to do this
and i'm a naturopathic physician I've
worked a lot of the bigger community
clinics in Portland and she's she's very
similar to real patients that I've seen
they're so so Natalia is a 52 year old
female returning to clinic with concerns
about an abrasion on her left ankle
possible infection she comes to the
clinic I'm a physician I'd never seen
her before but she's been seen here
before and right away I notices icon
which is the social determinants icon
this is only president of social
determinants are important for this
patient and it's also hovers over the HR
it doesn't look like an alert so it's
really noticeable and I noticed right
away that there's something flagged so I
can just hover my mouse over and it'll
expand out automatically and show these
highlights that have also been flagged
as being important for this patient
right away I noticed she's a diabetic
she's homeless which is really important
and she but she is living with a friend
she has housing looking for work and
that she has food insecurity she
plymouth snapped and also food pantry so
so you know i think that yeah it's going
to be important to what you know to work
with social determinants during this
clinic visit so i can i can click on
this list expanded icon and go to the
main clinician view for our application
so this this has three sets of data we
have the clinical data on the left the
social in the middle which are these are
Natalia's patient specific social
information and then the community
context which includes a map which is it
has a one-mile radius around where
natalia lives if Natalia was homeless
that radius would be one mile around the
clinic itself so I noticed right away
said she's taking metformin so I know
she's already on a medication I might
you know consider prescribing an
antibiotic too so I'm worried about
pharmacy she's in a new neighborhood
she's living in a new place you know
does she know where the pharmacies are
does she need a pharmacy that except
medication vouchers or she has support
for medication and also notice I'm a
clinical trend on the left on the bottom
or blood pressures ticked up a little
bit so I'm a little concerned about that
maybe I want to do something for that I
can go in I can click on the data points
i can get the the exact major IT she's
recently become pre hypertensives so
necessarily want to you know recommend
medication but i might want to recommend
exercise maybe diet but I know she's you
know as food insecurity could die
recommendations might be a little more
complicated but I can go to the map and
now i can pick out freeways figure out
free ways to exercise i can find parks
that are close to her i can find
community centers maybe even food
pantries for so if i go in on this at
the bottom i have data about the
neighborhoods so this is some of it as
if census data so this is this is all
neighborhood level data on the left i
can look at the walkability in crime
grade so i can be sensitive to whether
it's you know reasonable to recommend
walking in a park or in her neighborhood
so now i want to do some coaching with
natalia we have the patience you up in
the corner here i can click on that and
can bring up this view and i can have
natalia come over to the computer so I
can you know on the Left I can sort of
show some of the clinical data that I'm
concerned about and then I can go to the
map and we can pick out the resources
you know necessary to deal with some of
the issues that I want to
with her well then well then you know
the constraints of your social condition
so on this map I can click on icons it
will bring up the exact distance routes
we can figure that out you also click on
the legend up in the corner and that
that will either clear off things I'm
not interested in or you know only show
specific resources I'm interested in for
Natalya to help her so now I can print
this out give it to her with her after
visit summary and and and I you know
really was not much extra work I've sort
of added them with social determinants
into her clinical care the journey
dances from the blank slate for the
prototype that we've just demonstrated
for us as our design methodology we
selected agile and user centered design
integration and as the term integration
suggests this methodology takes
techniques from Adele designs such as
time box prints as well as techniques
from user centered design such as
collaborative interactive sessions with
end users to provide you with a
structured yet flexible approach to
identifying and addressing priority and
user needs we were grateful to have
broad clinical input in our design
process as Steve mentioned our target
audience was a medical home so we
selected representative end users
including nurse practitioners
naturopathic physicians social workers
behavioral health consultants and others
to participate with us in InDesign
sessions and these are typically
one-on-one due to scheduling and the
fact that they were all over town and so
we executed at least 20 of these across
the period of about three months our
work would split into three design
Sprint's the first each design sprint
had its own goal the goal for the first
print was really identifying what is our
concept we knew that we wanted to
address social determinants of health
and the institute of medicine provides
great suggestions about what types of
data you would like to include in the
EHR but it but we needed to understand
more about how you would do this and
what are the priority and user needs
that we really addressed in our
prototype we spoke with users about what
they do today and current challenges and
I'll just share with you one particular
visit that was really salient where a
behavior health consultant shared with
us that they had
tried the note they had tried the
problem list they had tried the barrier
section of the EHR and none of these had
resulted in the type of actionable
visible information that they wanted for
their clinicians and she said to us I
really need my clinicians just to start
seeing social determinants data so as
was mentioned in our design goals this
idea of visibility patient-centered
actionable data came out of our sprint
one in sprint 2 now that we kind of had
our concept refined we're like what
functionality do we need to put together
to really start to address these needs
and this is a very dynamic phase with
lots of iterations to the prototype but
I'll just highlight as an example of our
user input on the map that idea came in
early on but and we had a lot of ideas
of what we could actually share on this
map one idea was food deserts because
these are this is publicly available
information we thought it may be useful
for clinicians to know whether a person
lives in a food desert but our users
really pushed back on that and they said
you know you can live in a food desert
and have great access to food or you
cannot live in a food desert and have
food insecurity and so that they help us
refine this idea of narrowing it down
and really looking closely at the
aspects of the community that are near
the patient's residence our third sprint
focus on solution refinement our
prototype we have high fidelity
interactive prototype by this time we
wanted to go back to a lot of those end
users who helped identify priority needs
in the beginning and asked them did we
get it right is this something that you
could see using in your clinic and they
gave us great feedback and suggestions
for enhanced improvements like adding
public transportation routes or adding
additional support for capturing the
legal challenges that patients may be
experiencing and they also gave us some
initial feedback like the fact that they
really appreciated that this was not yet
another tab in the EHR and when they
learned that this was designed to be an
overlay over any a HR they said hey when
can we start using this in our clinic
and we took that as initial validation
that this concept may have the ability
to provide real change in the actual
live environment
so talk next we'll talk about the
application design in our future
evaluation looking at our appt at the
application a little bit more
conceptually we can see that we really
have one assuage intake form that kind
of drives three major components the
first is the hover icon that you saw at
the beginning of the demo then takes us
into clinician G which shows an
integrated view of the clinician or
clinical community and sth information
and then finally taking us into a
patient view which allows us the
patients become more engaged within
their own treatment plan since we
envision implementing the app using
smart smart platform and fast health
information resources or fire we wanted
to keep or we want to Center our design
around accessing a clean structured data
and implementing it with html5 from the
get-go we also in order to be able to
demonstrate or put forth the community
data we incorporated Google Maps
functionality walkscore calm for the
walkability in crime grade in the US
census if code data for more in-depth
community data while the initial
feedback during our syringe is positive
we solve a lot more work to do about our
evaluation we assume that we will be
observing and users in a lab setting as
they attempt to execute defined tasks
and we hope the setting will lead to
system enhancements and cruises and
crude usability we've also discussed the
possibility of incorporating the design
is an arm of one of ocean studies in
evaluating the best way to display sdh
data ocean is a nonprofit organization
organ that provides EHR functionality to
500 clinics across 18 states you serve
on serve underserved patients if the
design is confirmed to be to be useful
or helpful cochin could implemented a
production-ready version to these 500
clinics
in summary social determinants of health
is a pressing social social need and
should be addressed in any medical
setting you centered agile design helped
us confirm the valium feasibility of the
design another thing we all saw a lot of
fun be working on this and are happy to
see so much excitement from our end
users and ocean and and the potential to
evaluate and test our own prototype we'd
like to thank Rob chef and doctors
timbered oak and Alicia Boudreaux for
their guidance and encouragement and
we'd also like to acknowledge the many
clinicians and subject matter experts
you participate in our collaborative
design sessions and to the NLM for
funding the project a link to the live
demo is provided below at this time we'd
like to open the discussion to any
questions I just I'm just glad I'm not
on the judging committee and having to
choose between YouTube but you actually
have about a minute left so you have a
little little wiggle room that's great
thank you any questions
yes it's nice that one small caught like
a tiny thing I think when you initially
went over the hover icon to mention the
[Music]
social determinants of health so he ki
said something to effective this
indicates the social determinants of
health are important for this patient
sort of reward that so now social health
reporting for all patients but the icon
indicates if there's something specific
that you need to review for that patient
something along those lines just a small
thing thank you maybe the word pertinent
thank you any other questions yes that's
a really great point we didn't go into
detail on that but there is an intake
form that drives all three major
components of the application and in the
intake form under each category there's
there's a single line for a summary and
if that mine has been checked that will
auto-populate over into the highlight
that displays behind that hover icon
right those are free text forms in yeah
that's a short line of free text in the
applicant in the intake form that has
been checked as important to the
highlights thank you
you
any other questions yes the intention of
this slide is just to show that it could
hover over any EHR and we didn't want
people destructive trying to read and
just like with the clinical information
other questions all right well thank you
so much for your time and feedback
[Applause]